it's early in the morning an LD arrow
the trade winds are blowing the clouds
over the volcanic mountains this Spanish
island off the west coast of Africa is
almost always windy so why not make use
of it the smallest of the Canary Islands
is trying to realize big plans to supply
all of its around 7,000 inhabitants with
sustainable energy through a unique
combination of wind and hydro power the
energy shift has caused 83 million euros
and ran 20 million over budget critics
say that's far too much even if half was
covered by EU subsidies but the project
still has enthusiastic supporters para
meanwhiie positivo I think it's very
positive that El Hierro was able to
actually implement this project at the
beginning a lot of people doubted it
could be done but today it's a project
that works one that creates jobs and
brings in money in the next few years
it'll turn a profit the wind turbines
produce more than enough energy to meet
the island's own needs the extra
electricity is used to pump water 700
metres up to a reservoir basin it's 150
thousand cubic meters are a kind of
natural insurance against windlass days
if the wind power drops off the water
flows back downhill through a hydropower
turbine bridging the shortfall this
one-of-a-kind combination of energy from
wind and water is aimed at reaching an
elusive goal providing a steady unbroken
stream of power even when nature doesn't
play along but things haven't worked out
quite as planned because the region is
earthquake prone the basins had to be
built smaller than originally designed
providing the entire island with green
energy was always an ambitious goal and
it still hasn't been reached last year
the new facility only generated 40
percent of the power consumed on Ally
arrow
low calculus initially era the original
calculations were higher but structural
problems meant those plans couldn't be
realized what really threw them out of
kilter was the lower water basin which
we couldn't build to the size that we
wanted that's now proving a hindrance to
producing the amounts of sustainable
energy we want that's disappointed many
of the islands residents they'd hoped
electricity bills would fall instead
just like in the rest of the country
costs for power have actually gone up
that's because prices for energy are
regulated centrally in Spain lots of
people now say the project was all wind
and no substance
CNO Co Gallade they announced that our
island would be provided with 100
percent sustainable energy and that
hasn't happened we asked why not and
don't get any answers
somebody needs to explain to us why it's
not working the developers once promised
to shut down the old diesel driven power
plant but no one talks about that
anymore a fuel tanker still makes
regular trips to the island and the old
plant smokestack still blow lots of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere as
the brand new wind turbines spin on the
heights above the operators press
spokeswoman defends the expensive
investment she says that despite speed
bumps a euros energy mix is now much
more environmentally friendly than it
was in the past
let Brima Daniel open the first year of
operations in 2016 we saved nearly 7,000
tonnes of diesel that means we emitted
14,000 tons less of co2 and other
islands will profit from the pioneering
work we've done what do we get right
what wrong it's in the nature of things
that pioneering projects are
experimental and that they also serve to
help optimize future facilities the
engineers are certain they can improve
efficiency in their sustainable energy
mix but they've grown much more careful
about what they promised a series of
events is planned to reignite enthusiasm
for the project among residents and
encourage other islands to follow in
their footsteps
the UNESCO biosphere reserve is doing
its best to continue to be a leader in
environmental protection alghero used to
be viewed by European sailors as the end
of the world but when it comes to
shifting completely to renewable energy
at least it's now made progress toward a
new beginning
[Applause]
you